will have four
fellows from the data driven decision
making program giving talks and the
first talk in this session is estimation
of games under no regret by nicholas
okay so thanks hello so i'm a nikola and
i'm an economic
and today i'm going to present some
joint war with
lorenzo magnolfi in camindaron
the motivation is quite simple so many
data are generated by some strategic
interactions think for instance
of pricing decisions by firm
and the standard assumption in the
honorable ethics of games is to analyze
this data by assuming that they are
generated by equilibrium play in some
game theoretic models however important
economic environments are complex and
dynamic in nature think for instance or
of online marketplaces and because of
complexity equilibrium behavior is
implausible and therefore these standard
devonometric techniques for the analysis
of games need not apply
so what we do is to develop a method to
estimate the primitives of complex
dynamic environments
and we do so by following an adaptive
approach which is based on regret
minimization and the key intuition
behind our approach is to use learning
outcomes instead of solution concepts to
analyze from an automatic viewpoint game
dynamics
so what i will be doing today is just to
give you an overview of the main
economic game and economic theoretical
ideas of the paper with a very simple
toy model which is a pricing game
there are two salaries of a different
everything extends to any large large
but final game so there are two sailors
i
one and two time is discrete denoted by
n
and the environment is dynamic and in
each period n
the following happens first a profile of
marginal costs for the through fairs
the cost of for selling a gold realizes
each seller observes the marginal cost
and then set a price that can be either
low or high
at the end of the videos given prices
payoffs realize so profits realize and
each agent it said each seller observes
at least an estimate of the realized
payoff
assume that these marginal costs evolve
over time in an exogenous fashion and
the only thing that we assume is that
let's say each path or let's say the
empirical distribution of marginal costs
converge to some probability
distribution with some
full support on some set t what we
denote by the limiting stage game the
limiting stage game is the static game
the static pricing game
in which marginal costs are drawn from
this limiting long-run distribution
and actually this setting uh encompasses
many stochastic environments you may
allow for pets to perfectly persist the
marginal cost i add marginal cost markov
chains and so on
complete information is just a special
case of our setting and we only make
minimal assumption about what the
players understand about the environment
that is we know that each seller knows
the set of actions
observes the marginal cost for selling a
good period by period and at the end of
the period is able to at least estimate
what the payoff from setting that price
was
but not further common knowledge
knowledge or monitoring assumptions
and we have the following a homometric
problem in mind so the limiting stage
gain belongs to a parametric class
indexed by parameter lambda and we want
to estimate the through parameter in the
data generating process lambda 0 having
access to one of two possible data sets
the first one our time series data in
which we observe prices over time the
other one is simply a procession in
which we observe only an empirical
distribution of prices at some point in
time of course the 700 asset can be
derived from the first one but not vice
versa how can we hover lambda zero and
we do so in two steps in the first
step we assume a minimal optimality
condition on behavior which is we are
going to assume that players are able to
minimize their regret
and second and and then we establish new
home versions results of game dynamics
under the regret minimization
assumptions to the set of bias
correlated equilibria of the limiting
stage gain the through one given the
through parameters
let me be a little bit more precise
about that so let's treat each center
each type of seller as a difference area
so say a seller is identified by the
identity of the settler and the marginal
cost well since the external regret of
this less efficient player player is
said there is simply the regret
for not having played the best fixed
price in retrospect as we saw in the
first
week
then what we show
is that if each seller itis external
regret is epsilon close to vanish in the
long run
then the empirical distribution of price
is the time average of price profiles
converges to the set of actions which
are compatible with the bias correlated
epsilon equilibrium of the limited stage
gain
so let me illustrate that with the
numerical specification of our setting
the the of our pressing game the red
political part all actions which are
compatible as
bias correlated epson equilibrium
actions and this is the time average of
play over time produced using a very
simple actually
algorithm regret matching and as you see
as time goes by the time average of prey
of play approaches the set of bias
correlated epsilon equilibrium
predictions and stays there forever
after this means that after some time on
the time average of play enters the
neighborhood of this set and stays
inside this neighborhood forever after
but may keep moving inside this set and
this is actually the fact that making
moving is bad from the viewpoint of
learning again but as you will see it's
a good news from any homometric
viewpoint
the second step
is to define to recover estimators of
this parameter lambda 0 using the
restrictions that are
implied by the static equilibrium notion
of bias correlated action equilibrium
and establish the home variance
properties
so you can think of at least two
estimators given our data generation
generating process one is simply the
plug-in estimators this gives you all
possible parameters lambda which are
compatible with a single empirical
distribution of prices as a bias
correlated epsilon equilibrium action
profile for the gain
but if and this one can be computed both
with cross-section and time series data
because what you need is just a single
empirical distribution of prices however
if you have access to the time dimension
we have
access to time series data you may think
about intersecting plug-in estimators
for values for various way
values of n
and what we show is that
both estimators
almost surely as n becomes sufficiently
large contain so the through parameter
of interest is inside is inside this set
so we started to take aways of this one
first of all is that
a well-defined static equilibrium notion
which is biased related equilibrium
gives us practical and useful
restrictions to estimate interactions
which are dynamic under weak assumptions
on players knowledge and behavior in
this environment we simply assume that
they minimize their regret and
importantly cross-sectional data surface
are sufficient to obtain estimates of a
dynamic interaction we don't need to
have access to the dynamic to time
series data however time series data
allows us to refine
our bounds basically to gain
informativeness of our estimation
strategies why this comes from the
properties of regret minimizing dynamics
as i was saying
if players are minimizing regret the
time average of play enters the set of
bias correlation equilibria but may keep
moving therefore if it keeps moving
inside the set at different points in
times you observe with a different time
average of play which corresponds to
different bias correlation equilibrium
action profiles of the through limiting
model and this one can be leveraged to
refine the information of our bounds and
i'll show you that with an illustration
let's consider now marginal cost which
are for simplicity across players and
and over time and we want to recover
from the observed play the variance of
the marginal cost distribution
and what you see is that
for for relatively large value of
epsilon this corresponds actually a
small number but in terms it's a
percentage of
deviations from perfect regret
minimization so it's like in the order
of five ten percent depending on on on
the on the player you see that all
all estimated sets these are the plugin
estimators at different points in time
contain the through parameter of
interest which is one but if you take
the intersection of just three of them
you see that your bounds consists are
considerably refined are considerably
more informative than just by picking if
like a single plug-in estimator
so what we do is also to implement an
empirical application with our method
and what we do is to study cellular
pricing behavior on zwopa which is a
decentralized online marketplace for
portable electronic devices
we scrape data for the most common
iphone models and we use our model to
estimate the distribution of sellers
marginal costs i don't have time now to
to give you the results but let me say
that what we are going what we are
working on
these days is to use these primitives to
basically conduct market design
experiments and address market design
questions such as evaluating what is the
degree of competition in this platform
or or to see what would be prevailing
prices if we give these these sellers
access to built-in algorithmic pricing
tools in the platform so there are let's
say several questions follow our
questions i'm happy to talk about them
um afterwards
and
thank you
thank you questions
both of you can ask
like um
what do you get ultimately is it like a
compact set for the the the parameters
or yes yes the the we all get always get
a convex say
and then you would have to take some
center if you wanted to have say one
value you would have a one value one
value is inconsistent with this mode you
cannot get because these are partial
identification exercises so you you
there is no criterion to pick one and do
you have a sense of like if you were to
use in this in practice if there is any
form of non-stationarity like that in
the sense of you need this limiting uh
kind of point yeah so
what how would that kind of affect your
ability to use this methodology if you
don't have a
at least this exogenous process if it
doesn't have a long-run empirical
distribution uh
we don't know what would happen because
we cannot define the limiting object
which is bias correlated equilibrium
which allows us to
which gives us useful and practical
restrictions to estimate the the model
but that's interesting but we don't know
what would happen we have to go
probably to use a different approach
thanks the next speaker can set up
so
this is how i reach the problem
i have a game that is changing again
again but there is a planted
process
it is parameterized by one parameter and
what i want to discover actually is that
parameter
the the that is the code right
yes so
i'm confused a little bit about why it
is a convex
in other words i cannot have something
like an unbiased estimator i understand
that there is variance but
can i have an unbiased estimator for the
lambda our estimator is a that's
precisely the the point of partial
identification
and incomplete models so basically this
one will never give you point
predictions unless you
have
you know covariates or or other things
let me ask a question that it is yes or
no if i have a
infinite sampling can i prove that i
will converge to one point no no no you
cannot prove it like i cannot have a
large law number no you do you do but
you do it but it's applied to sets and
not two and not two point estimates
because the estimator is a set
i see the symmetry set because of the
epsilon no no no even if you set epsilon
zero to zero you say it
because i said
yeah yeah okay we'll have an interesting
question this guy yeah yeah yeah true
right thanks for the nice talk um